98%の人たちは流されているとで
2%
の人だけが流されないんだとお金のルール、税金のルールっていうのを知ってるだけで資金繰りってガラっと変わるので
AIDX
かが進化していけば知っていくほど人の魅力っていうのがやはりビジネスに直結するんじゃないかなと僕は思ってますので知識というのは価値を生み出すための素材でしかないと青木久の人生警額
[音楽]
[音楽]100回聞いたから豊かになる話
。
皆さんこんにちは。え、今日はですね、え
、スペシャル対談ということで、え、
134万人のですね、チャンネル登録者を
誇る、ま、日本で最もある意味で人気の
ある、え、お金のプロ脱税理士原君優一
先生に今日はですね、来ていただきました
。え、菅原さんありがとうございます。
よろしくお願いします。
もうね、本当にお忙しい中。
いやいや、もうおかげ様で本当
もうなんか最近あまりにも有名になりすぎて
電車に乗れないってこと聞きましたよ。
そうなんですよ。もう最近新幹線以外に乗れてないですね。
そうでしょ。
タクシーに乗っても
うん。
ね、タクシーの運転士さんからあ、菅原さんですね。
そうなんです。意外とタクシーの運転士さん見てくれてるんですよ
ねえ。ま、それぐらいもう本当に有名人になって
その100万人超えると
はい。
ちょっとこれは国民的スターの領域に入るからちょっと注意しなきゃいけないかなとね。プライバシーがなくなるんじゃないかなと。
そうです。それはありますね。
でしょう。ああ、心配してます。
で、私も菅原さんのチャンネルにもね、この後あの出させていただきたいなと思ってますので、
ま、色々ね、
ともかく菅原さんとは講師にわってとっても仲良くしてるんですけど、
あの、人柄がね、とっても素晴らしいんですよ。
トータルでこれ3
日間の研修何回受けてくれたかな?
ま、21回ですかね。21
回でしょ。
今日はね、あの菅原さんのね、顧問先って、ま、
85%以上が
黒字じゃないですか?
それを
実現しているね、そのエッセンスというか、
その辺のところをですね、今日あの有料級の話ですけども
はい。
え、是非ね、え、ちょっと対談の中で話をしてもらいたいなと思ってます。
ました。はい。
まずこの85%
の人が黒じ、ま、その経営者がね、
黒じっては
い。うん。
もうこれお客さん寄りみしてるわけではないわけでしょ。
ないです。ないんですよ。
それはどうしてそうなるのかちょっと話をしてもらえません?
そうですね。もう僕たちのコンサルティングってある意味方がありまして
うん。
まず1
番最初にお客様と、ま、コンサルティング始めさせていただく時にお客様の実現したいビジョンをお聞きして、まず最初丸
1日かけて一緒に事業計画作るんです。
うん。
あ、お客様が描えてるものを僕も同じように描けるように一緒に事業計画を作ってまずこっからスタートなんですね。
なるほど。
はい。よく経営者さんで
うん。
税理士さんがアドバイスをしてくれないていうね、不満がよくあるんですけど、
これ僕税理士だけのせいじゃないと思ってて
うん。
お客様が税理師に
ここを目指してるからそのためのアドバイスをして欲しいっていうことを伝えてないんですよ。
うん。うん。
うん。
伝えてないのに税理士側がアドバイスはできないので、だからまずは社長が税理士にどこを目指してるからそのためのサポートお願いします。まずこれが大前提だなと思ってますね。
なるほど。
今の話を聞いてね、私は、ま、ナポレオンヒルのナポレオンヒル財団のアドバイザーであり、ま、先日あのゴールドメダル授与したんですけど、長年にわって研究してきたことが人の成功と習慣と自己実現の関係。
成功者って基本的には方向性持った努力してるんですよ。
で、今事業計画を立てる指導をするって言ってましたよね。
これポイントですよね。
そうですね。そうじゃないと流される人
つまりナプルーンヒルは
98%の人たちは流されていると
ああ
で2%の人だけが
流されないんだと自分の頭で考え
自らの意思で自分の未来を作っていると
うん
まさにこの事業計画を立てるところで明確な目的と
目標をクライアントと一緒に立てて
は
そこをまずセットアップするんですね。
そうです。
そして事業計画を立ててその通りにこう指導している。
そういうことですか?
うん。そうです。
なので私のクライアントはもう皆さん事業計画を作ることが大前提なんですよ。もう事業計画なんていらないっていう方は契約しないので。ま、そういう意味ではちょっと選んでるのかもしれないですけど。
[笑い]
選んでるね。選んでる。実際選んでた。実は選んでた。あ、なるほど。
ま、ある意味で素直に菅原先生の助言をうん。
受け入れる
うん。
そういう向心のある
前向きな経営者を選んでるということですね。
そうです。その通り。
その通りですね。
それはそうだよね。
あとそう。これこそ青き社長の講義を聞いた中でなるほどなと思ったことがあって
うん。はい。
コンサルタロットの方で成功したければ
成功者をコンサルティングすることだって社長講義の中でおっしゃってたじゃないですか。
まさにそれだなと思ってやっぱり同じアドバイスをしても動く人と動かない人ってやっぱりいるのでも成功者の方ってもう自ら動いては
結果出してくれるので
なんでまず最初事業計画を作るっていう部分を素直にやってくれるもうその部分で自ら動ける人ので
まそういう意味で85%黒字
ていうのはうん
なんか達成してるのかなと思いますね。
[音楽]
なるほど。
今日、ま、このチャンネルをね、見ていただいてる方に、ま、是非ね、僕は菅原先生のあの塾にもね、行ってもらいたいと僕思ってるんですけど、
[音楽]
その経営のそのポイントとして、ま、塾でどんなことを教えてらっしゃるのかとか、その事業計画を立てる、ま、その塾にね、是非行ってもらいたいので、
そのなんかポイントみたいなものがあったらちょっとお話したけません。
私たちの毎月あのオフラインとオンラインで経営の勉強化してるんですけど基本は税務財務会計なるほど。
お金回りの情報とか、
ま、テクニックというか、そういう部分も含めながらお伝えはしてます。
あのルールを知ってるのと知らないのでは全然結果が変わってくるので、それこそア社長がよく言うはコストないですけど、
やっぱりお金のルール、税金のルールっていうのを知ってるだけで資金グリってガラっと変わるのでその辺はうん。
[音楽]
あのYouTube
で言えないことも含めてお伝えはしてますね。
それポイントね。[笑い]
YouTubeで言えないことを
その塾に行ったら聞ける。
聞ける。[笑い]
これはね、皆さんね、是非ね
言ってください。あ、
ありがとうございます。
あの、お勧めします。
うん。
ところでね、津原さん
はい。はい。
黒字化できる経営者と
赤字のままずるズる行く経営者の
違い。はい。
何が違うのか根本的な違い何だと思います?
はい。これ僕はあのこだわってることがありまして、もう
PDCをかに回すかだと思ってて、
先ほど事業計画を最初に作るっていうことをお話したんですけど、僕あのよくダイエットを例えるんですね。
[音楽]
うん。
ダイエットする方が例えば
3ヶ月後に何キロになるて言って、
ま、ダイエット始めるわけじゃないですか。
うん。
毎日体重に乗ってる人がブクブク太ってくてないと思うんです。
うん。なるほど。
必ずそっちの目標に近づいてく。う
ん。うん。
でも多くの中小企業の経営者は事業計画をまず作らない、作ってもほったらかし、ま、体重系に乗らないみたいな感じですね。検証をまずしてないで改善もしてないなのでこの
[音楽]
PDCA
を検証改善を繰り返していけば悪くなるはずがないと思うんですよ。
なるほど。
すごくシンプルだと思うんですが、このシンプルなことがほとんどの方がやっぱ赤字の会社はできてないです。
これがまず第ですね。
そうですね。はい。
素晴らしい。
ちなみにPDCA
を回したくない人っていないと思うんですよ。
でも回せる人と回せない人の違いは何ですか?
やっぱそれを管理してくれる人が身近にいるかどうかだと思います。どうしても後回しになっちゃってできない人が多いですね。で、僕たちはもう毎月
2時間必ずクライアントと会議するので、
PDCA会議っていうの毎月あるので、
そこで先月の数字の検証をして、え、じゃあ改善するためにはどうしていこうで、この
ヶ月何取り組んでいこうっていうのを毎月必ずやるので、悪くなるはずがないですね。
[音楽]
うん。うん。
当たり前のことを当たり前にって言うけど、その当たり前がまず分からない人もいるし、
それから当たり前のことを特別に、しかも徹底的にやり続けるって言うんだけど、やっぱりね、なんだろう、安きに流れてるんだよね。うん。ね。
で、日常のまさにこうさに追われたり
緊急感覚でろんなことが飛び込んでくるのでうん。
おそらくね、ま、そういう確なコーチ、まさにメンター
良き指導者が
いればね、
ちゃんとそのちゃんと戻してもらえるけど、
ま、経営者特にそういうある意味ではこうなんだろう殺されてるっていうか
日常忙しいのでそうね。うん。
え、そういうことなるんでしょうね。うん。確かにそれはあると思いますね。
うん。うん。こう自分自身の人生すらこの
98%
の人は流されてるってことだったんですけど、この顧問先の人にもこの
時間の会議した後にじゃあこれをやりましょうとなったことを実行してもらうって結構難易度あるなと
思ってしまうんですが、その実行していただくポイントってあるんですか?
はい。これはもう本当社長次第んですよ、実は。
あの、1
ヶ月経って何もしてませんでしたっていう社長もやっぱいるんですよ。そうすると赤字です。
やっぱりやっぱりもう完全にもう先月の会議で決めたことを
ヶ月やってきた方はやっぱり業績上は向いてきますね。
そうだよね。
うん。
実はね、経営者がどうしても磨かなければならない能力の中に
3つ、1
つはね、判断力ってあるんですよ。
うん。2
つ目はリーダーシップ能力、そして
3つ目が今の話です。実行力なんですよ。
で、この3
つの能力を高めるためにはやっぱり菅原先生の指導が必要だと
ねことだね。いや、つまりやっぱりそういう指導をしてくれるから
うん。
85%の人はみんな黒字になるんだと。
そうですね。
よくわかった。
はい。素晴らしいと思います。
それをしない税理師さんもいるわけじゃないですか。
それって何でなんですか?
はい。あの、これは税理士は税務のプロであって経営のプロではないんですよね。
でもそこを社長さんたちは経営もアドバイスしてくれると思って相談する。ま、ある意味ミスマッチが起きてるんですよ。で、僕は税理士なんですけど税務が得意な経営コンサルっていう、ま、そうやってに自分でやってるのでなので、ま、お客さんの業績を上げることが僕の仕事だって思ってるので、ま、それが税理士の中でもスタンスが違うんだと思います。
そう考えてる人が少ないんだろうな。
うん。うん。事前の一手は事後の100点
に勝さるとだからこの事後対応に追われて
バタバタ貧乏で終わってしまう人と事前の
一手常に何をすることが最も効果的かそこ
に向かって生きてる人っていうのは少ない
わけですよ。
だから今の話税理先生もしかしたら自分の人生に明確な目的目標持って生きてないのかもしれない。
そうかもしれないですね。
ね。
で、ま、顧問になれば毎月サブスクじゃないけど一応顧問料入るじゃん。
そうですね。そうですね。
うん。
だ、そういう意味では
新規開拓をが困ると
うん。
努力するけれど
なかなかやっぱり流されてる税理先生も多いのかもしれない。
多いと思いますね。うん。
いや、これはなんかすごいね、大きなポイントかもしれないね。
うん。
あともう1つですね。
はい。
今後の中小企業経営者のその最も頭に入れとかなければならないこう課題
中小企業系における課題ってどんなことだと思いますか?
今の時代はですね、もうAI
がどれぐらい使いこなせるかって結構皆さん興味を持たれてると思うんですけど、多分もうそれは当たり前になって、そっから違いを生み出してかないといけないので、やっぱり最後は僕は絶対人だと思ってるんですよ。
AI、DX
かが進化していけば知っていくほど人の魅力っていうのがやはりビジネスに直結するんじゃないかなと僕は思ってますので、人間力を上げていくというかね。
うん。なるほど。
ファンをつける。それこそアチーブメントさんでもね、
B2F
ファン、ファン作りってね、あの、研修もされてますけど、本当それだと思いますね。
はい。なるほど。
ま、知識というのは価値を生み出すための素材でしかないと。
うん。
そこからどんなレシピでどういう味付けをして最高の料理を作るか。これは人間にしかできないですから。知識ではなく知恵の領域ということなんでしょうね。なるほど。勉強になりました。
いやいやいや。[笑い]
ありがとうございます。
はい、ありがとうございます。
先生に顧問をお願いするもう枠はあるんですか?もう、もう受けてないんですか?
もう4年ぐらいちょっとストップさせて
[笑い]
なので、今そのSMG
刑塾っていうね、塾をしてるんですよね。
そういうことか。そういうことだ。
だ塾に来てもらって魚を与えるんではなくて
釣り方を身につけさせるという
自装型の経営者を育てようっていうことでその軸の中で計画だとかそういうことの
重要性とかもちゃんと具体的に指導してるわけね。
そうですね。
なるほど。
で塾の中でも合宿であの
2泊3
日の画宿でそこで事業計画を作りましょうっていうのも半年にちょっとやってるんですよ。
ああ、よくわかった。なんか俺も行かなきゃだめなんじゃないよね。
[音楽]
いやいや、そ[笑い]
何名ぐらいいらっしゃるんですか?自分さん。
今2300名ぐらいますね。
うわ、日本一だね。
いやあ、本当ね。
すごいな。
ちょうど2年スタートして
年ですけど、まあ、ここまで伸びると思わなかったですね。
素晴らしい。
うん。
これからもですね、是非菅原さんとはね、仲良く長い障害のお付き合いしたいと思ってますのでよろしくお願いします。
何か、あの、このチャンネルを見、僕のチャンネル見てくださってる方に一言あればちょっと言ってください。
はい。そうですね。僕、あの、本当
年前にアチーブメントに出会って、それから半年に
度は必ず受行するっていうのを決めて、今
21回10
年受けてきたわけなんですけど、本当それで人生は変わってきたなと。あの、よく遅れの法則ってア、社長の講義の中でもいいます。あの、言っていただいてますけどとここ数年でその成果コツコツみ上げていた成果がやっぱやっと出てきたなっていう感じですね。
継続することがやっぱり僕は1
番の力だと思ってるので、え、是非ね、これチャンネル見られてる方、自己生の方多いとは思うんですけどね。
はい。はい。
時間が空いたら受けようとかじゃなくて、もうつ受けるっていうのをもうルーティンにしていただきたいな。そしたら絶対に結果出るのでね、なんか一緒にった皆さんと学べたらなと思っております。
[音楽]
ありがとうございます。いや、私はね、やっぱり共にね、社会を良くする活動だと思っているので、うん。
良質の情報との出会いは人生を根本から変える時が
うん。うん。
私是非ね、菅原先生の本当にあの塾にもね、多くの人行ってもらいたいと思ってます。実はあの菅原先生にはですね、先日世界で
[音楽]
冊しかない特版の本をね、プレゼントしたんですよ。あ、持ってきてた。嬉しい。
これ、これがそうです。はい。&グローリーチで実はチャンネルの中で菅原先生、菅原先生のチャンネルですよ。
この拒否を築づく思考法について解説して
くれてます。これも週一なので是非ですね
、このチャンネルの方も見ていただきたい
と思います。菅原先生のチャンネルにも私
も出ますので、ま、是非楽しんでください
。え、今日は本当にありがとうございまし
た。菅原先生、これからも紹介よろしくお
願いします。ありがとうございます。
ありがとうございます。じゃあ皆さんの
チャンネルでまたおめにそして、え、
コメント欄に是非お忘れなくなくコメント
お願いします。
あとそう、チャンネル登録忘れてる方は
是非チャンネル登録してください。菅原先生のファンの方を是非私のチャンネルもよろしくお願いします。
また次回目にかかりましょう。ありがとうございました。
ありがとうございました。
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに掘れ込ん
でるかどうかなです。[音楽]